Speaker 1: Let's go next
to Spencer from California.
Spencer, go.
Speaker 5:
Hey, David, thanks for taking my call. So. I
think one thing that we encourage is, or at
least you encourage on your show is teaching media
literacy and viewing it as something that has a
positive impact on in terms of educating people.
Yes, I was reading an article which says that
part of the way we teach media literacy
is telling readers to critically think
about how information is constructed. Who's
paying for it and what's being left out.
And as a result, this leads to some level of
distrust and maybe even hostility towards new
forces the way that we learn it, and maybe
this even drives some ethical ization. So
what's the right way to develop media
literacy skills while trying to prevent
this effect of causing people to have this
predisposition that media is not to be trusted?
Speaker 1: You know, I thought that the caller
before you was one of the best calls we've had.
This may be in contention for one of the best
calls. This is a perfectly constructed question,
so your question is a brilliant one, which
is if one has not been exposed to. The basic
skepticism that we should bring to any messages we
receive, and this means a sign on the outside of a
building, a TV commercial, a news report. If your
first exposure to this type of critical thinking
is in media literacy, you might incorrectly
develop a hostility towards media because
you've never thought about this framework before.
And all of a sudden you're being told we've got
to apply it specifically to media. You're 100
percent right. And so what we need to do is
that framework of how to think about things, how
to know why we believe the things we believe it
has to be introduced earlier before the context
is even media literacy. And here's what I mean.
If two years before media literacy becomes
a topic, you are generally instructed on
how to evaluate whether something should be
believed or not. And it's applied to everything.
It's applied to the things your classmates say.
It's applied to all sorts of phenomena. Why? Why
do you believe? How do you know what your age is?
How old or how old are we kids were seven. How do
you know that? Do you remember each of the seven
years? Well, no. It's because our parents told us,
OK. And how do you right? So if you first develop
that as a general framework for evaluating why we
believe the things we believe once it's applied
to media, it shouldn't generate that sort of
distrust and you're 100 percent correct.
Speaker 5: Yeah, I think that makes a
lot of sense. And then one more question.
Speaker 1: Sure, it's going to be I mean,
you know, you may want to go out on top, but
but let's see. I don't know if the next question
could possibly live up to the first one there.
Speaker 5: So maybe on a sort of related issue,
how do you respond to friends and
people who are simply misinformed,
but they're not too far removed
from reality in their beliefs?
So, for instance, maybe someone who thinks that
Biden is largely responsible for gas prices,
they might have just heard that somewhere
and blindly repeated it. Yeah, without
checking for themselves. And in essence,
what I'm asking is, what's the best way to
confront these people and tell them that they're
wrong without seeming too argumentative or just
flat out telling them that they're incorrect?
Speaker 1: Oh, I mean, that one's very easy,
particularly if it's people you
generally get along with. You would say,
Oh yeah, it's interesting. Biden's responsible
for the high gas prices. Tell me more about
that. What? What did Biden do to raise gas prices?
And almost certainly they're already going to go
nowhere. And then I would say, Oh well, because,
you know, gas prices are up in every country.
Does Biden affect gas prices in every country?
And if so, how? I mean, I would just diffuse
that with some very light questions.
Speaker 5: Right. Yeah. I was
thinking that was the approach to go.
Speaker 1: All right. Excellent phone
call. I congratulate you. Thanks for taking my
call. All right, very good, guys. I'm almost
scared to take the next call because it's going
to be very hard to live up to some of these.